hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast applying a single cell
gps to discover
novel spatial biomarkers and ffpe
tissues i'm susie valdez of elaborates
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
akoya biosciences the spatial
biology company for more information
about our sponsor please visit their
site
at aquabio.com so let's get started
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive and we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click that send button if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
simply click on the support tab found at
the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd now like to introduce our presenters
dr coda
milwaukee physician scientist at keushu
university dr aaron mehrer co-founder
and chief
scientific officer at enable medicine
and dr
oliver robot senior manager of the
applications
at akoya biosciences for a compute
biography of
our presenters please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
drawback welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
thank you very much for this
introduction and thank you everyone for
joining our webinar today
my name is oliver and i'll give you the
intro to the following two speakers koda
miyawaki from kyushu university
and parent mayor at enable medicine who
produced the study that we will be
talking about today
titled applying a single cell gps to
discover
novel spatial biomarkers and ffbe
tissues
so i would like to lead off this webinar
by talking about high dimensional
biology with
codex technology
high dimensional biology or in-situ
phenotyping
will in our opinion fuel decades of new
discoveries
and what you can see here is biological
tissue
actually a piece of breast cancer is
about two millimeters from bottom to the
top
and three and a half millimeters from
left to right this tissue
is stained with seven different
biomarkers you can see them here
in different colors now if i toggle
through this slide
you can see another four different
biomarkers plus gap beats
here are another five biomarkers each
one of these images
shows you a different biology about this
tissue
this type of experiment this type of
high dimensional biomarker labeling
is your sense of phenotyping every cell
is registered
and every cell is marked with a
combination of many different biomarkers
in the case of this experiment i have
just gone through 32 different
biomarkers
here are four more but all taken taken
together
there are 36 biomarkers on this tissue
this is a highly multiplex
analysis of a breast cancer tissue with
codex
you can resolve up to 40 different
biomarkers or protein targets in an
intact tissue
thus you can conduct your phenotyping in
situ
once again it is extremely high
dimensional very very informative
about what is happening in your tissue
now one of the things that is absolutely
crucial to spatial biology is that every
cell is accounted for
and you can see this in this slide this
is a boronopla
which is essentially a spatial map of
phenotype
cells represented against its true
background
so every cell here is registered as it
has either a green
or a yellow or a blue item in the
position in which the cell is found
you have red basal cells for example you
have green
other types of epithelial cells you have
a stroma and blue
every cell is accounted for in a codex
experiment
because you have true single cell
resolution
you can also see a testament plot here
on the bottom left
this is another representation of these
cells each dot is one cell
each color is one phenotype this result
is akin to this result it is the same
thing
but two representations are side by side
now in a codex experiment
as i said before you have high biomarker
flexing ability you can look at many
different biomarkers
that every cell is accounted for because
this technology
relies on optical microscopy which gives
you single cell
access so how does codex system work and
what is the coded system
codex is essentially a microfluidic
device that you can see here
this is white and blue box approximately
the size of a benchtop printer
and it has a series of valves and pumps
that
handle fluids that are required to run
this experiment
this system is based on epi fluorescence
microscopy and connects seamlessly with
imaging system
like the cans bzx unit you can see that
right here
so side by side these two units do not
take up very much space in your
laboratory
they fit on any bench top and it's
readily compatible
with epi fluorescence imaging systems so
this is a
system that you can easily import into
your lab and it shall not have a very
big footprint
how does the codex experiment work in
it's a sense
codex is ultra high flex
immunohistochemistry
so what do we mean by that what you can
do in a codex experiment
is you can design an antipod antibody
panel 40
or more antibodies each antibody is
conjugated to an oligo
you can see this little red line here
there's your antibody in black
little red line is your oligopoly once
all of your antibodies have been
conjugated with
oligos you can stain your tissue all of
the antibodies go on to your tissue at
once
this is the only manual handling step
that you need to do
incubation time is the only time it
takes that you have to wait
once the antibodies are on there the
tissue is labeled you can walk away from
it and the machine takes over
it's important to note here that this
one step staining procedure
is done with reagents that we provide to
you all of the oligos are provided
of the reagents um permeabilization
solutions fixation solutions and so on
and so forth are provided to you
but one question that is also important
to address right up front is about the
antibodies
so some antibodies for example an
antibody against cd4 or cda
are inventoried by us that means you can
buy them off the shelf
however there are many others that
people are interested in these are not
readily available in our inventory
in that case you just take whatever
antibody you're interested in
conjugate it with our oligo and thereby
make it compatible for the codex
experiment
so it is very flexible and adaptable for
your type of research if you like
now once your tissue is labeled it goes
into the codex system
and goes into the imager and what
happens is all of your antibodies that
are now on the tissue
label with your oligos will be um
revealed with oligosequences that have
fluorophores on them
so what happens is the machine dispens
dispense
three different types of fluorophores
each one has an oligo that is
complementary
to three antibodies microscope then
takes a picture
you can see that here this is what we
call cycle one
after cycle one is completed the
reporters are removed
cycle goes back tissue is now unlabeled
with fluorophores but still has the
primary antibodies on it
the machine then proceeds to add three
more reporters on it
these are three reporters that have
different oligosequences in the first
round
thus the microscope can take a different
picture that's all you would see in
cycle two
this repeats itself until all the
antibodies
up to 40 or more that you want to look
at
have been imaged you can see that here
this is a sequence of 16 cycles
each image is completely different than
the other one but every time
we're looking at the same tissue this is
spatial biology
this is how it works and this is very um
robust experiment
one of the things that's very good about
this experiment also is no stripping
involved
so it's rather gentle we don't there's
no heat treatments
involved it's isothermal reactions and
finally there are no host to host cross
reactivities
so this unlike one two
immunohistochemistry
power detection is oligobased so you do
not need to worry
about post-host reactivities background
and other types of messy interactions
that we observe with conventional
immunohistochemistry
that's what makes this system possible
and
that's what gives you a very clean
result from cycle to cycle
now lastly i would like to say that
codex is widely deployable
again this is based on conventional epic
fluorescence micro
microscopy so it allows you to access
and image
tissues that you would expect from any
other type of
fluorescence imaging experiment so here
you can see melanoma
brain lung skin kidney
spleen even blood cells all of these are
codex data
each one of this codex experiment that
was done on different
type of tissue different preparation
ffpe
fresh frozen human hormones it's
extremely widely deployable
and compatible with many different
preparations and i'm very excited today
to introduce an experiment that was done
on human gut tissue
by coda and enable medicine as a
collaboration
and what they did is they studied graft
versus host disease
which is a an immune reaction that
occurs
sometimes when people obtain bone marrow
transplants
where the donated cells wrongly attack
the gut
or the epithelial layer of the gut i
mean i'm
not very well known but the experiment
for us was very interesting because it
shows once again
that this type of biology is highly
relevant in making new discoveries
and problems that we face today in
health care
so with that i'm really excited to move
on over
and pass it towards coda who will
introduce to
gvhd and will introduce the experiment
and
hopefully you will enjoy the next part
of this webinar as well
you for your kind introduction oliver
hello everyone
my name is kota miyagi from kush
university and i'm broadcasting this
webinar from japan
i am researching hematological
malignancies such as leukemia and
lymphoma
as a hematologist in the next 30 minutes
i and aaron will show you our study
titled
high dimensional mucosal and lymphofile
predict prognosis of gut gbt
i'm really excited to share our
experience of analyzing using codex for
getting closer samples and i'm hoping
this will provide you with some
information which helps you out
to apply the codex analysis into your
research
and expand it
i think many of the audience are not
familiar with gvgd
so let me start with the quick intro of
this disease
and also i will explain why we are doing
this research
gvhd which is evaluation of
growth versus host disease is the major
complication during hematopoietic stem
cell transplantation
also known as bone marrow transplant
as you might know hematopoietic stem
cell transplantation
has been curing option for patients with
blood cancers
sometimes it could be the only option
for cure
in this process patients blood cells
including immune cells are wiped out
and if released by abdominal derived
blood cells
sometimes donor derived immune cells
attack the patient's healthy tissues
such as
gut liver or skin because they originate
from
patients i mean host which resulted in
seb inflammation
and tissue damage this immune attack
from donated
cells against host tissue it's called
gbhd
when gvg occurs in the gut stevia
inflammation is observed in the gut
mucosa
as shown in this endoscopic image
gut gbt is a common and significant
complication
and can be lethal when patients
experience severe gut gbt
like grade 3 or grade 4 disease zero
survival would be only 25 percent
so the successful control of gut gbt is
a critical factor of prognosis for
patients after transplantation
current standard of chaos therapy for
gas gbt
is a systemic administration of steroids
but a substantial number of patients
eventually elapsed
and their prognosis is inferior as you
can see in the survival curve
therefore we would like to know the
prognostic factor
like who will respond well to initial
search therapy
which can help us to design the optimal
treatment strategy
and also we would like to know why some
patients are refractory to steroid
therapy
this situation led us to launch this gbg
study
in recent years thanks to many scientist
efforts
we have studied to understand what kind
of immune reaction takes place in the
gut
i started this figure from naturally
paper
you can see that various immune cells
such as
muscles or granulocytes or negative
lymphoid cells
which the essential players in innate
immunity and many t-cells
and these immune cells interact with
each other in response to gut microbiota
are playing a critical role in gut
health
however as of now which immune reaction
affects the clinical cause of captivity
is still unknown
so we set the aim of this study to
understand
the underlying mechanism of gut gbt
primarily focusing on their clinical
costs
for this purpose we first tried to
understand who is the prognostic
determinant among
various immune cells in other words
we attempted to identify
self-populations
associated with the prognosis of god's
gvgd
also we try to unveil how they interact
with each other
the mechanism associated with clinical
behavior of gap gbt
such as steroid responsiveness
before diving into results part i should
tell you about the methodological
challenges in this research
the biggest research barrier was the
sample limitation
because the samples of gut gbt tissues
are obtained by endoscopic biopsy
from severely ill patients who are
suffering from severe diarrhea
the sample size and the number of
tissues are
small and limited in general
in addition to that biopsy samples are
usually
archived as hormone fixed tissues called
ffp
tissues so most of accessible samples
for gbg research is limited to ffp
samples
generally speaking rna or dna extracted
from ffp tissues
is severely degraded
and is not suitable for whole
transcriptional license
such as iron sick because they are
already effects we cannot dissociate
tissues and
generate a single cell suspension which
means that
it's hard to perform singles analysis
such as single-cell and sick or
sight-off for cytometric analysis all of
which are
procedure for the global immune
profiling
to overcome these limitations we utilize
two novel technologies and kernel system
from nanostring and the codex system
from akoya
here is the overall methodological
design for first study
first we performed global gene
expression profiling
using the anaconda system encounter
is probe based rna profiling technology
and
enables accurate gene expression
profiling even in rna from
ffb tissues in this plot
we compare the gene expression data from
two replicated experiments
using the anaconda system and try to see
the data's reproducibility
you can see how the data are accurate
and reliable
this means that this system can
accurately detect genetic expression
even from minor immune cells in the
tissues
using this system we evaluated 800 of
immunity genes including cell surface
markers or
functional molecules which define immune
cell populations
and we combined a gene expression result
with
clinical parameters and try to extract
gene
genes linked to clinical outcomes of
gupta
in the next step we performed multiplex
imaging analysis by codex with the help
of aaron from enable medicine
we stand the gut gbt tissues with 38
antibodies
and performance hypox spatial analysis
to
validate and expand an endocrine
analysis result
and again we evaluated that these
results in combination with clinical
parameters
we first expanded our noise by combining
the spatialized result
and gene expression results
aaron will talk about codex analysis in
detail in the latter part
before that i'll tell you a little bit
about what we get from
endocrine analysis
here is the volcano plot a simple and
common solution to compare gene
expression levels between two groups
and find out genes that are specifically
articulated in
either group this volcano plot tells us
which genes are regulated in steroid
responders or non-responders
each dot represents each gene analyzed
by encounter
so this should be 800 dots here
the x-axis represents the differences in
expression levels between two groups
and y-axis represent statistical
significance
genes located upper right should be
favorable prognostic genes and
upper left guides should be
non-responder specific genes
and we categorize these genes depending
on cell types by color as shown here
including t cells or macrophage subtypes
and try to discover cell populations
that
are specifically associated with the
patient's clinical outcomes
in contrast most of the macrophage
specific genes shown in red
were regulated in non-responders
these results motivated us to see
whether
we can stratify patients by muscle or
macrophage signature
and are associated with prognosis
this hitman figure shows the results of
the hierarchical clustering analysis
muscles and macrophage signature genes
were represented as
green and red respectively
gap gbg patients could be catabolized
into three groups
the muscle group up regulated only
muscle genes
macrophage groups specifically upper
regulated macrophage genes
and the intermediate group includes
samples that express both muscles and
mass
fracture phase genes and samples which
express neither
as you can see in this couple of mayo
curve the overall survival of the muscle
cell signature group is much better than
those of macrophage signature
thus we demonstrate that the
immune-related gene signature
clearly reflects the prognosis of gap
gb3 patients
now this result was a following question
do they really exist in the tissues
how do they interact with each other to
uncover the background mechanism
we proceeded to the next step codex
analysis
here i'd love to pass over the mic to my
collaborator iron
uh who made an outstanding contribution
to this study
here explain how we performed codex
analysis and
how we interpreted the data
thanks coda at enable medicine we were
very excited to team up with coda on
this particular project to employ the
codex platform to study gvhd
we thought that codex would be
particularly well suited for providing
insights in dakota's questions
due to its ability to simultaneously
look at a variety of cell types
their functional states and interactions
in general at enable medicine we
specialize in the generation and
analysis of highplex imaging data
this includes all the way from six to
seven color immunofluorescent images
such as those acquired with the
phenoptics workflow
up to 40 plus biomarker images acquired
with codecs
we're working on the development of
novel machine learning and computer
vision algorithms
to provide new insights into spatially
multiplex data
for this particular project we worked
with coda and his team
and to develop a custom 30 plus
biomarker panel
here are some examples of the various
biomarkers included in this high plex
gvhd codex panel
you can see that these markers range
from identifiers of cell type
such as cd3 cd4 and cd8 t cells
cd68 macrophage and mast cell tryptases
to tissue markers including cd31 vessels
and photoplane and positive lymphatics
and furthermore markers a cellular
functional state such as ki 67
a common marker of cell proliferation
this slide highlights the results of
this 30 plus plex codex panel applied to
a gut biopsy taken from one of coda's
patients with gvhd the first thing you
can appreciate
is the beauty of this multiplex tissue
data as the image flashes you are
visualizing various combinations of
biomarkers from the codex panel
on the same tissue section
now if we slow that down and look at
just seven markers from the panel
you can appreciate right away the tissue
structure and cellular organization of
the gut
that codex allows you to visualize here
you can see a zoom in of region one
depicting gut epithelium
highlighted by cytokeratin in the cyan
color
you can see cd8 t cells infiltrating
this tissue in blue
some of these cells are proliferative as
observed by co-staining with ki-67 and
yellow
you can see mast cells in the tissue
highlighted by mast cell tryptase and
magenta
and a lone regulatory t cell in this
zone indicated by fox p3
in green in region two we're
highlighting lymphatic vessels
outlined by protoplaning staining in red
now this is just one set of seven
markers taken from this codex panel
and you can already appreciate spatial
organization and complexity at the
cellular level
we acquired these codex images on all
tastes on all patients from kodus gbhd
cohort
and that allowed us to qualitatively
observe how the expression these
different markers varied as a function
of disease state
here we are highlighting increased gvhd
score in the gut as you look at these
patient biopsies from left to right
and you may be able to observe increased
inflammation breakdown of tissue
architecture and changes in the various
expression levels of these biomarkers if
you look closely
but what we want to do more than this
would to be able to quantify the data
and discover features that statistically
affect prognosis
patient outcomes and disease progression
well we can do just that utilizing a
cell segmentation algorithm
we are able to segment out all the
single cells from coda's gbhd gut
biopsies
and essentially create a high
dimensional single cell data set
without ever needing to grind up the
tissue in this way
each cell can be represented
mathematically by its expression of
various biomarkers and its spatial
coordinates
which are retained in this example we
are highlighting a segmented cell that
is positive for ki-67
cd4 fox p3 and cd3 while being negative
for cd8
the immunologists in the room likely
recognize this right away as a
proliferating regulatory c
cell but how do we go about
automatically and systematically
identifying and enumerating cell types
across the cohort
for this challenge a variety of
algorithms can be selected from
depending upon your study goals
in this case we wanted to get an
unbiased look into the cell types
present in the gut gbhd samples
so we ran unsupervised clustering on all
of the single cells that had been
segmented from coda's images
in this 2d representation of high
dimensional space known as a force
directed layout
each dot represents a cell and each
color represents a cluster label
the cells cluster together in space
based on their similarity to one another
as determined by their biomarker
profiles we can visualize this in a heat
map like format where red is high
expression and blue is low
and look at the expression of various
markers in each of the clusters the
algorithm has a sign
in this way we can then go through and
label the clusters with the cell types
they represent
for example this cluster here in the
middle high for photoplanin expression
we labeled as lymphatic endothelial
cells
on this slide we're showing just another
representation of the clustering results
that groups the cells together
and allows one to more quickly evaluate
the relative frequencies of each cell
type
for example many cells were classified
as lamina propria and epithelium
in cyan and teal respectively as would
be expected for the gut
you can then compare this with the
varying population sizes for the
infiltrating resident immune cells found
in this cohort
with this framework we've now shown how
coda has the ability to quantify
biomarker expression
in changing cell frequencies between the
gbhd patients
but our analysis allows us to go a step
further
since codex maintains the cell spatial
coordinates we can map the cell types
we've just identified through single
cell analysis
back to the tissue here i'm depicting
that as we move from the multiplex image
at left
to the cell type map at right
in these cellular maps which we refer to
as voronoi diagrams
each cell is represented mathematically
in a graph type fashion
each cell is depicted with a color and
letter label for example you can see
mast cells in red
labeled with the letter a the power of
these cells map
the power of these cell maps is they
allow us to mathematically index
each cell and compute its interactions
with its neighbors
these interactions can be cell cell
contacts or higher order neighborhoods
of cells that may be present in the
tissue
the graph at right shows the cell cell
contact network diagram
where the bar size represents the cell
frequency and the cords represent the
contacts
so for example this green cell here
which is the cd4 t
cell is interacting highly with the
landmine appropriate in this particular
patient's tissue
seen by the cells in blue with these
tools in hand
coda went back and tested his hypotheses
regarding gut gvhd and patient outcomes
he will now share with you the
preliminary results from the study
thank you aaron in the study
we prepared 28 got gbt specimens
all of it were obtained from endoscopic
biopsies
we need to place slice xfp samples on
the coverslips in codex analysis
as shown in this image
among 28 samples we could successfully
obtain
image data from 26 specimens including
10 responders and 16 of non-responders
as shown in this chart
from this slide i will show the result
of codex analysis in number tvg study
we first analyzed whether or not must
cells or macrophages
actually exist in the gut gbt tissues
and evaluated their frequencies
here shows representative two cases
cmz 16 from the responder group who
survives more than five and a half years
after transplantation and cmdb31
from non-responder group who
unfortunately died from
severe gbc reaction only four months
after transplant
macrophages are shown in purple and
muscles are shown in yellow
you can see that eoms cells are
scattered around
the tissue even in the low power image
and responders
and the number is much larger than
non-responders
in a similar way purple macrophages are
abundant in the non-responder group
we can confirm the number and morphology
of muscles and
macrophages in the high power image more
clearly we next analyze whether or not
the number of muscle cells
or macrophages are associated with
patients prognosis
we divided patients into two groups
depending on the number of
observed muscle cells or macrophages in
codex analysis
in the left copper molecular survival
curve the blue line represents the
muscle cell rich group
and the orange represents the muscle
four group
as you can see the mast cell rich
patients showed better survival compared
with
muscle cell program in contrast in the
right survival curve
macrophage rich patients showed poor
prognosis
now we can confirm the existence and the
number of muscles and macrophages in the
gut gbt tissues
tightly associated with patients
prognosis
in the second part we focus on the cell
to cell interaction
and understand underlying mechanism of
how muscle cells or macrophages are
associated with gbt prognosis
through these analysis or we found mast
cells
might directly suppress immune cell
activation
as aaron explained in his word we
analyze
cell to cell interaction based on their
proximity
and try to understand which cell
interaction is most associated with
prognosis
again here shows the volcano plot but
this time each dot represents certain
cell interaction
not gene expression from this volcano
plot cell to cell interaction between
mast cells
and the lamina propria macrophage or
cd1cdc generating cells
or cdat cells is most associated with
favorable prognosis
and macrophage interactions such as
laminar proprio macrophage
with cda t cells or cd1b macrophage with
cda t
cells are most associated with
proprognosis
we can confirm these results in the
tissue image obtained by codex
uh for example in the responder group
muscle cells and cdat cells frequently
exist adjacent to each other shown in
the upper fluorescent image and showing
the lower image from burner
analysis
in the nonresponder group macrophages
tend to reside
next to cdit cells in these images
we can also quantify these cell-to-cell
interactions
on the tissue by tissue basis and
compare them between the responder
non-responder groups
we can observe marked difference in
specific cell-to-cell interactions with
statistical significance
and validate the four kind of plot
results
among many prognostic cell-to-cell
interactions
we are focusing on the interaction
between muscles
and seriousness disease dendritic cells
as shown in the roc curve the
interaction between muscles and
insidious diseases seem to have
strong predictive power in the codex
image
cd elementary dc yellow cells line up
along the intestinal
epithelium shown in blue in the basal
layer
you can see the interesting
morphological observation of c11cdc
with bodily body morphology extending
dendrites into epithelium junction
and the muscles shown in red often exist
adjacent to cd11cdc's
as shown in the dot products the
cellulose interaction between muscles
and cdlgdc
is much more abundant in the responder
group
and survival analysis clearly shows the
prognostic impact of this surgical
interaction
as a favorable prognostic signature
next we focus on another favorable
prognostic interaction between muscles
and cda cytotoxic t cells
and this time we added another parameter
functional parameters ki-67 into the
analysis
as you might know ks67 is a well-known
proliferation marker standpoint and the
curious
let's look at this image and please
focus on the cd8 positive set of 6t
cells stained by magenta
the cell stand both in magenta and
yellow represent pretty full leading
cytotoxic t
cells they are cycling and cells express
the only magenta represents
resting cytotoxic t cells and we notice
that cytotoxic t
cells adjacent to muscles tend to be
k-67 negative
then we quantify the expression level of
ki-67
in cds toxic t cells and the distance
from muscle cells as shown in this
figure
most of the cytotoxic t cells located
near my cells are resting
these results suggest that muscle cells
might directly
suppress toxic t cells and contribute to
the inflammation suppression
finally we combine the cell to cell
interaction data from codex
with gene expression data from endocrine
analysis
through this approach we found that
macrophage interaction are associated
with inflammatory
gene expression
as shown in previous slides macrophages
are associated with
unfavorable clinical outcomes and here
we evaluate the correlation between
specific cell to cell interaction
and gene expression and try to explore
the novel link between them
as a result we found that cellular
interaction between macrophages and a
lymphatic endoserial cell
is tightly linked to atg7 expression
as the top-ranked correlation among all
combinations
we observed a marked expression of atg7
in the non-respondent group and in these
cases macrophages and lymphatic and
serial cells
are spatially associated with each other
adh7
is an ultraphosgene protein and
according to the paper published in this
year
87 is a critical regulator of
inflammation
and promotes industrial cell
permeability
and inflammation so this data suggests
the possibility that
ad7 expression induced through
interaction with macrophages
could be functional molecule and
contribute
to seven inflammation and prognosis in
macrophage rich gut gbt patients
as we wrap up the results from this
study
in the gut gbc patients muscles may
contribute to favorable clinical
outcomes by directly suppressing
cytotoxic t-cells activation to reduce
inflammation
and interacting with relevancy disease
also macrophages may be associated with
proper analysis by disrupting either
serial cells and contributing to
information
presumably through the interaction with
atg7
in the future we would like to know the
underlying mechanism
more precisely which is what determines
the muscle macrophage signature
here is today's recap we demonstrated
a proof of concept study of aquaria
codex
in ffp gbg gut specimens
enable medicine performed acquisition
and analyze of high flex codex data
i will discuss new specialized methods
including correlation of cell
interactions
with cell state and gene expression data
codex life is identified and validated a
novel cell signature associated with
gvgd prognosis
correct reveals several potential
biological mechanism
thank you for your attention and we are
happy to take your questions
thank you dr miawaki and dr mayor and dr
bravax for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar and if you
have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so let's get started it looks like we
already have
some great questions coming in i'll
start with you dr barlock
our first question thank you do you need
to use
the secondary antibody
um that's a good question um so
basically
in this system we do not use secondary
antibodies
um so what happens is your primary
antibody
is conjugated or tacked with an
oligonucleotide sequence
and then the way we visualize that
primary antibody
is via a fluorophore that has a
complementary
oligosequence on it so rather than using
a secondary antibody to detect your
primary you now use an oligo that has a
fluorescent tag on it
the advantage of doing that is that you
don't have to strip
the oligo and the fluorophore off of
your tissue
you can dehybridize it or you can use a
solvent to remove it
which overall is a much milder effect
than what you would have
if you take primary secondary antibody
detection
then lastly this also has the advantage
that it
prevents messy let's say non-specific
staining of for
for example when you have a secondary
antibody that is raised in a mouse
it oftentimes binds to non-specific
epitopes in the mouse tissue this does
not happen in the codex system
because again it is oligobased so
long answer here but the short short
answer is
no we do not use a secondary antibody
thanks for that one
thank you so much and dr mayor this
question is for you
how do you conduct cell segmentation
using vulneral and what is the merit
cell
segmentation using phonology
thanks that's a great question so first
the clarification
the cell segmentation itself is actually
performed using algorithms like
watershed
which are traditional cell segmentation
algorithms to isolate
the cells you could also imagine using
a novel sort of computer vision or deep
learning approaches
to apply your cell segmentation the
voronoi is just a way to visualize those
results
so the voronoi is actually a
mathematical or graphical representation
of the data
and it allows you to be able to compute
edges between cells
as well as distances so the voronoi is
quite
useful for visualizing the data whereas
the cell segmentation is done earlier
during the processing of the images
thank you very much and i want to thank
our i think
yes i want to thank our audience members
for these great questions
coming in our next question and either
dr barbach or dr mary you can try this
one what
tools can be used for the analysis of
high plex
codex data and does acquia offer them
or does one have to use let's say a
third party tool
oh i can take this question here aaron
so what tools can be used for the
analysis of codex data
the very simple approach is to use our
own built-in software which is called
the multiplex analysis viewer or math
this is an image j-based plug-in that is
provided free of charge to anyone who's
using codex or who's interested
in codex you can actually download this
software today
and request sample data sets to practice
on your data analysis on some imaging
data that we can provide to you
just go to our website and request it
there
regarding third-party tools all of the
data are structured
as as tab comma separated values
so really the raw data look very much
like let's say single sequencing data or
something so you can export these data
readily
into any third-party platform that
you're
interested in so we see a lot of people
exporting our data
into r or python
some people use sirat plug-ins so it is
based on the raw data structure very
versatile
and very easy to move it out and into a
third-party platform if that is what you
prefer
thanks for that thank you so much
and dr milwaukee this is a question for
you
mast cells are usually easy to see
in h and e sections are the
immunomolecular trigger i'm sorry
immunology
modulatory mast cells seen in this study
evidence in the original hme section
thank you um it's a very good question
and
unfortunately we didn't uh check that
um we didn't stain any marker or muscles
in an
80s but we we didn't check the
muscle cells and in hd section
i don't think i think we need to
thank a specific muscle marker
to detect it
thank you so much and dr bravoc if you
try to detect
several or many cd markers that you
predict to express in the cell
don't the antibodies physically
interrupt each other and
this is a two-part question from our
audience member if the receptor
occupancy of each marker is quite high
won't any interruption happen
that's a good question we get that
question often um
we do not have any empirical evidence
that this happens
um thus far there is no no confirmation
that this happens i think on a
nanoscale level you will predict that
it's very very much possible
indeed but we have not been able to
demonstrate that
i'd also like to note that some of the
highest plex
antibody applications of codecs or
similar systems
they go beyond 40 biomarkers which is
what we're offering commercially
for example at stanford they're using 56
biomarkers and generally
a large majority of these biomarkers are
cluster differentiation marker
biomarkers so cd molecules
like the ones you're mentioning and to
my knowledge this has not been an issue
or this has not been demonstrated
so with what we provide you i don't
think you need to worry about this
um there should be no interruption and
you should be able to faithfully detect
the cluster differentiation
antigens on the surface of your cell
that you are interested in
thank you thank you so much
and again i want to thank our audience
members for these great questions coming
in
and if you have a specific question for
one of our
presenters you are more than welcome to
add their name to your question
as well dr miyawaki this question is for
you
it looks like you placed multiple biopsy
fspe sections on the cover slip can you
share any tips and tricks on how this
was done
yeah thank you um it was a very good
question and
yeah it's very tough to
um place multiple
sections in one cover suite but um
definitely it can it can save you a lot
of cost
so i um
some lab technicians
could not do that but uh one
we have unfortunately we have very good
talented
love technicians and she helped me out
to place uh to make this section
so i think um we can communicate
the privatery so please give me the
email um
actually um the email the
hypeblex and enablemedicine.com and uh
i can answer personally thank you
and thank you so much and dr mayor dr
braubach i'm gonna
ask this next question and one of you
can decide who wants to take it
i understand that a queer has several
panels of
antibodies how did you validate the
antibodies specificity
and how do you validate the specificity
of antibodies
that have highly homologous
family members
that's a great question i'll chime in
here first and then oliver can follow up
so in general one can make custom panels
and uh there's several ways that you can
go about validating
the panel first off i'll say the
antibodies that are known to work well
in your tissue of interest whether
that's ffpe or fresh frozen
um are a good place to start then those
would be conjugated
with the bar codes that oliver was
mentioning earlier to prepare them for
the codex workflow
and then you would stain your tissue
first potentially
in experiments where you just use that
antibody alone
as well as in combination experiments
where you apply co and counter stains
this allows you to test if the pattern
follows the standard morphology that you
would expect for the stain
as well as to compare it amongst things
that you would expect it
that it should stain with and things
that you expect that it would not stain
with
there's a number of steps that can go
into validating this such as also
including positive and negative control
tissues
and i'd be happy to discuss offline the
full process of how we validate antibody
panels for different settings
oliver do you want to take it from there
oh yeah so i think aaron captured the
gist of this here
essentially what we do in house is
every time we we test a new antibody or
we
produce a new antibody for that matter
we do a side by side comparison
of a codex antibody that is an antibody
conjugated to an oligo and detect to be
an oligofluorophore
versus a conventional primary secondary
antibody
detection method this is done on
adjacent sections of the same tissue
and side-by-side analysis is performed
then we do
antibody titrations to see whether or
not the antibodies behave as
expected so they should give you lower
signal with
higher dilutions and vice versa and then
we
address the antibody specific
specificity
by a rigorous regime of taking the
antibody in question
and counterstaining it with multiple
positive and negative controls
this is in a regional and in a cell
specific environment
so overall that gives us a very good
idea of um
if they're on if the antibody specific
and only antibodies that pass
that um qualification will be
deemed validated lastly i would like to
mention that we work in close
collaboration of course with the
antibody suppliers
we don't make the antibodies we work
with antibody companies
and they of course will reconfirm
whether or not our antibodies
are doing what they're supposed to do so
rest assured when we say it's validated
you can be pretty sure that it's
labeling what it's supposed to
thank you
thank you so much sir our next question
dr broadwalk is for you
are there any tissues which is hard to
analyze utilizing that codex system and
how about bone marrow sample can you
tell us a little bit more about that
yeah that's a brilliant question of
course there are tissues that are hard
to analyze using a codex system
there are tissues that are hard to
analyze with any system for that matter
so bone marrow is tricky um i think
that's tricky for codex and any other
any other technology that's imaging
based
the problem with bone marrow is at this
stage there's still
no consistent decalcification method
that everybody agrees on works
so the problematic of doing bone marrow
imaging
already starts when you're at the
cryostat or when you're sectioning ffpe
getting good decalcification is very
hard and that translates all the way
back into your codex experiment
i've used to work on bone marrow and
what i notice is that the cells in the
bone marrow are very small
and they're extremely densely packed so
when you're looking at
cluster differentiation markers in bone
marrow it's very very difficult from an
analytical point of view to really
confirm to really get
unambiguous labeling of cell membranes
to segment them
and then they do analysis so yeah there
are some difficult tissues
but um i hope that in the introduction
of this talk we have demonstrated that
you can use codex in a wide variety of
tissues
some difficult ones include it and we
believe that
there will be more and more tissues
added in the future and
i can tell you that there are several
people working on bone marrow
but the the outcome of those studies is
still to be seen
so thanks for that
and thank you sir and dr mayor this next
question is for you how can we get the
cellular interaction
information after we decide each cell
type
and by the distance between each type of
cells or maybe
by other information
thanks for this great question so uh the
the question is right on here because we
have the spatial coordinates of all of
the cells in a codex experiment
were able to look at its nearest
neighbors and so you could imagine that
simply as the distance from the cell of
interest
so that's how you could compute these
sort of cell cell contacts or
nearest neighbors you could also imagine
uh defining a larger area
you could call this a neighborhood and
you could ask for a particular cell
um you know what are all of the cells
that are around it in
uh in a you know 10 cell radius or you
know it's 100 nearest cells what are
those all like
and you can actually use these types of
approaches to define neighborhoods that
exist within the tissues
as well as compute the cell cell
contacts
thanks for the question thank you
dr milwaukee this is your question
coming up and again i just
want to thank our audience for these
fabulous questions coming in what a
great
q and a we are having today qvhd
often affects mucosal stem cells by
causing
apoptosis i apologize if i didn't
pronounce that right
it's a handful what about the proximity
of the mast cells and other immune cells
to the mucous cell stem cells are they
good responders compared to the
proximity
of the macrophage to the mucous cell
stem cells and
are they poor responders can you
elaborate a little bit more for us
yes um yeah this is
um another great questions uh you're
right um
many of the previous research
shows the tight concordation between the
causal must stem the codon stem cells
and gvtd
but unfortunately we did in this
analyzer we
focus on more on the immune cells
and not to um
the causal cells such as um godot stem
cells
or secret secretory cells so um
yeah it's very interesting and
i will look into it in the next step
i will look into the relationship
spatial research between stem cells
and muscles or macrophages so thank you
for suggestion
and thank you and all three of you thank
you so much for your presentation today
and for your important
research we want to thank you for
your time today and we also want to
thank akoya biosciences
for their sponsoring this event today
and
for being a part of this event
i also want to thank our audience
members for their interesting questions
and for joining
us today questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
be provided at the time of registration
can view this webinar on demand and lab
roots will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
thank you again dr milwaukee dr mayor dr
broadbach
and thank you again akoya biosciences
until next time
everyone stay safe stay healthy and go
bye